[Music]
oh no it's a code red coke okay we're
late we're live let's roll let's go
i'm zoey dj let's go
up and adam and this is paul good
morning
we turned our two families into one all
right rise and shine
wake up ella or this video goes on your
instagram in three two dad no touch me
lose a finger good morning to you too
luna strong choice suggestion take off
one thing solid advice
dryer's broke again how did you get down
here so fast laundry shoes let's go
let's go let's go
we're not a cult oh but we're weird
we're one of a kind all the way thank
you thank you very much thank you thank
you thanks
i really feel like there were a few
extra children in there i didn't
recognize some of them
where are the bakers
ten kids and no nanny wait you have 10
kids shockingly i enjoy being with my
kids
i do too you too yeah i do too
you guys are funny
go to your room but do you want to do it
dance with us because we're so
irresistibly adorable you're not even
doing it right you have to clap the back
of the hands and then throw you're
embarrassing the family go to your room
oh lord get me straight
it's important to show the kids that
we're united who invited the jackson 9.
if y'all looking for disneyland you made
a wrong turn
[Music]
family has each other's back oh my god
everyone's looking at us
oh
thanks for being so average and
relatable paul with average looks and
ordinary body wow
what are you guys playing drag race fun
i love
[Music]
so you guys weren't having a fast and
furious style race for money whoa
i just realized we're not smarter than
you